الغربيه استشهد فجر اليوم شابين فلسطينيين
برصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده قباطيه
جنوب شرق مدينه جنين وذلك خلال اشتباكات
اندلعت خلال تصد الشبان الفلسطينيين
لاقتحام قوات الاحتلال للبلده باكثر من
اربعين اليه عسكريه وافاد شهود عيان بان
الشبان الفلسطينيين اكتشفوا امر قوه خاصه
من المستعربين لدى التسللها الى البلده
بلباس عربي ما ادى الى دفع تعزيزات كبيره
من قوات الاحتلال لتوفير الغطاء وحمايه
القوه الخاصه التي اقتحمت البلده فاندلعت
مواجهات اسفرت عن استشهاد الشابين واصابه
العديد بحالات اختناق جراء اطلاق قوات
الاحتلال لقنابل الغاز السامه
من جهتها اعلنت حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه ان
الشهيدين ينتميان لسرايا القدس ذراعها
العسكريه واكدت في بيان صحفي استمرارها في
مسيره الاشتباك مؤكده ان ردها ات بما
يوازي حجم جرائم الاحتلال بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني ومجاهديه وقد شيعت بلده قباطيه
جثماني الشاهدين رامي قطنات 25 عاما من
مخيم جنين والشهيد احمد عساف 18 عاما من
بلده قباطيه اللذين استشهد برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في اشتباكات المسلحه
عند العطف البلده خلال تصدي الشبان
الفلسطينيين لاقتحام قوات الاحتلال